foreign
Erin hi Erin uh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally I'm from
Cleveland Ohio Cleveland tell me about
your family growing up
um so
up until the age of three
um I lived with my biological parents
um and then I was taken away from them
because my father was caught molesting
and abusing my brothers and sisters and
I
um they didn't like catch him in the ACT
but it was
found out through our behaviors because
this
sexual behaviors manifest you know
um and like they would catch my brother
and I doing absurd things so I got
placed into foster care when I was three
and then finally adopted when I was
seven by the same lady who originally
took me in it just took her a while
because the court proceedings
um and then it really wasn't any better
uh as far as neglect and abuse codes
there was no you know molestation it was
just a lot of abuse
um
does that I can go into details do you
want me to
sure just a little bit
um so one time
I like
I was angry at my mother so I like I
scraped up the wallpaper in the bathroom
like made marks in it with like a Lego
or something
and so she revoked my bathroom
privileges for a full year and I had to
like defecate urinating in a can in my
bedroom
and I would have to use the kitchen sink
to take a sponge bath before school in
the morning like literally no bathroom
privileges
um on the regular she would beat me with
like
um these orange driveway markers the
fiberglass ones
and they would leave two beating on my
my behind
and leave welts you know but it was
always on my behind so I wasn't going
around advertising it you know and no
one was asking any questions
um
and I believed like
I wasn't allowed out much so I wasn't
able to see how other parents treated
their children
so I didn't know that I was in like a
really dark screwed up situation you
know what I mean
but um so that's like a few tidbits and
then uh
oddly enough she died when I was 15.
um I got put back to foster care because
uh
My adoptive brothers and sisters you
know they they didn't feel like I was
their responsibility
um that was my mother's responsibilities
she'd passed away so
you know well I I don't know for
somebody that I wasn't that
responsibility
um so I got put back into foster care
um up to that point like I had really
like just kind of screwed off in school
and whatnot but I really buckled down I
remember my senior year
I only had like six credits going into
the year and you need 22 in the state of
Ohio to graduate and I was able to get
all of my credits plus some
and graduate on time
um I took on like a like a
class load of like
it was like three years of school work
within a year and I did it you know it
was really cool I scored super high on
my acts and I graduated and was
emancipated from the state of Ohio
when I was 17 which at the time I'm like
oh cool you know look at me hot shot but
I later found out that if you were
awarded the state
um until you're 18 on your 18th birthday
you're still one of the state the state
has to pay for your college education up
until you're 26. I didn't know that
there was a money scheme and that
getting me expedited out was the way
they could save money
um either if I'm not out because my
sister managed to stay in the foster
care system
until she was 18 and she had her
schooling paid for it
um
which
really cool but um so yeah that was like
life growing up it wasn't very fun
um
so like I kind of after graduation I
like
I didn't like nobody could really tell
me anything like as far as like what to
do because like I had two jobs I had my
apartment you know what I mean and it's
quickly spiraled out of control
as far as like I was drinking a lot
um
and uh
I started doing cocaine started smoking
crack
and uh I ended up smoking crack for two
years
and at that point I was drinking every
day at the height of my drinking I was
drinking like a fifth of rum and a 12
pack of Bud Ice
every day
um but weirdly enough I got sick of the
hangovers I could not do the dehydration
and like the dry heaving and like the
shakes like to where uh one day like
I didn't realize I was going through DTS
for three days but I was I thought I
just had a really bad hangover and after
that I'm like
I'm I'm good on the drinking and then
with the crack smoking
um I
I received a felony I sold someone's
credit card
and ran up a thousand dollars on it
didn't realize at the time that you know
if you're gonna do that kind of thing
just keep under a thousand
um so then I've had my first
introduction to the judicial system
um
they placed me in drug court
um which I ended up not completing it's
another one of those things where it's a
money scheme because if they they're
allowed when you're placed into drug
court you're a lot they're allowed to
tell you what to do
uh where to go when to be there what
time to be in you know um and if you
don't follow those rules they can put
you in jail
uh kind of evil you know
but um
so yeah that
brings me up to right before I came to
California because I'm only 26.
um I don't want to share my age but yeah
yeah I'm only 26. um I just turned 26.
um
so
I was um
I read this book like four years ago
three years ago
and it was uh it's called a bright shiny
morning
uh it followed the lies of like eight
different people who lived out here in
California
and it was really kind of cool because I
mean I liked it a lot because
um I'm pretty free spirit I heard a lot
about California you know being a free
spirit
and this book kind of put all like like
put into perspective for me like what
life was like out here
um I really kind of excited me you know
but I had never even left the state
you know let alone like go 3 000 miles
away
and uh
I knew that I wanted to come here but I
didn't know how it was going to happen
and uh all I knew is that I was I was
starting to come into like uh starting
to realize that I could manifest things
in my life
um if I focus on them correctly
um so I was using meditation
and I would meditate every morning
um meditate myself into a better mood
because I I would wake up naturally and
just be like Angry every morning you
know and it was very hard to function
like that you know
um so I would wake up and do this
meditation to kind of like reset my mood
into a more positive State and at the
end of The Meditation I would
close it with I'm going to go to
California
I would just say that once and then you
know I'd go out with my dad I did that
for
like six months no no no I only did that
for like three months and then there was
three months I didn't do it
and I was just kind of
you know just live my life drinking you
know whatever
and um
uh at the end of the three months the
second three month period I was at a bar
drinking and this guy had asked me uh
you know what my story was and
I kind of lied to him and told him that
um I was from California
and to my surprise he he's like do you
want to go home and I said yeah
like I remember just being like super
excited you know and uh he was like well
I'll buy you a bus ticket when we're
done here I'm like
so sure enough we finished our drinks
and he took me down to the Greyhound
station and put me on a bus and I came
here with nothing I mean I didn't really
have anything to begin with you know
what I mean
um
and I've been here ever since
so yeah how long has it been like three
years three years what have you been
doing since you got here
um so I used to cook back in Ohio I've
I've had a couple jobs out here like
working on food trucks
um nothing too big though
um I spent a lot of time on the beach
you know kind of kind of being a hippie
um a lot of people look down on that
lifestyle but like I have a lot of pain
that I'm trying to work through
um
and like
that like the time I've spent on the
beach I've done like a lot of like soul
searching you know a lot of like
um
practicing opening my eyes and trying to
see the bigger picture you know because
I'm learning that there's like
there's a lot more in life than
for example me and my pain you know
there's this other side that's like
okay put my me and my pain aside there's
people out there who've been through the
same thing that I've been through and
I've got great things yeah not only that
but who have yet to do the great things
and need help you know and I'm like
um like the only way I'm gonna be able
to heal is if I help these people I
don't know why but like in learning
things
you never because I taught myself to
play the tuba and play the guitar
growing up and I was never able never
able to fully like Master like a certain
piece of music or whatever or certain
technique until I taught it to somebody
else then I like knew the entire scope
of it you know
so I'm like a firm believer that like
um I need to get better so I can help
others get better and then in turn help
yourself yeah so we all Elevate I buy
that 100 percent
so are drugs still a part of your life
yeah I still struggle
um
but you know I'm a lot
um blessed like um
there's a lot of people out here I'm
fentanyl man and like I I heard
there's someone talking about it earlier
and like
it's like I've had to I've had Narcan
eight people this year you know and like
I've become
like numb like when it happens like I
know exactly what to do and whatever I
don't freak out but I'm numb to it you
know because I've seen it I'm like
desensitized because I've seen it so
many times I'm like I don't want to have
to keep doing that to people your drug
is crystal meth yeah my drug is Crystal
math
but like I said I'm like blessed that I
haven't slipped into the hands of
opiates you know
um because that kills people and only
that like it changes people literally it
changes your brain chemistry
and
granted so does mess but like there's
something about like
meth is mentally addictive like I don't
I don't have mad I'm not like crapping
myself or throwing up you know I I can
make it through my day
to the next day eventually I'm gonna
want to pick up again but I can make it
through situations that I need to make
it through
why I've noticed with opiates people
like they cannot do anything without
that drug and they will do heinous
things
like like um for instance like they'll
agree you know the day prior to do
something the next day it's of extreme
importance and that involves other
people
and then the next day they're not
prepared and they don't have their drug
and so all these other people are
affected because of one person you know
and it's really kind of [ __ ] up
screwed up excuse my language
um
so yeah I I feel blessed that I'm not
like I mean and I I
I really want to like quit using meth
because it's part of the reason I'm so
homeless
um
because like
I like whenever I I was housed like six
months ago but I'm still I was still
hanging around the Shady people you know
I'm bringing them to my home and my
landlord seen them I was like and then
it caused friction between us
me my landlord which eventually LED it
to me like I got I left before they
evicted me but um it eventually led to
that you know what I mean
um
negativity breeds negativity you know
um
what's your biggest fear now my biggest
fear right now
getting shot or stabbed
um because I see it happen
to people I see guns a lot
and like
um
and also fighting I I've never been in a
fight out here on the streets
I usually don't let [ __ ] stuff escalate
to there
um
I'm pretty good at like just Meandering
through situations without
well I don't want to say like I can
pretty good like
getting a read on people and when to go
home you know because I I growing up
seeing all the like violence inflicted
on me and then around me like it didn't
do any good you know so like I'm just
it's unattractive to me there's some
people like fighting and I'm just like I
mean I like arguing debating you know
but why would you want to why would you
like getting hit in the head or you know
why would you like the fear of losing
your life you know I that's can't call
it insane but it's like uh because I
don't think it fits the definition but
it's definitely uh
unhealthy mental illness is everywhere
on the streets but you know I think my
like
part of my uh
me not liking to fight
it's part of my mental illness because I
think humans to some degree need that
fight in them you know what I mean
because if you don't fight if you stand
for nothing you'll fall for everything
I liked her sometimes like this morning
I ran into a guy
who stole my blanket
and I don't know what else he took for
me
um
and like I just kind of like I realized
what had happened that he was the one
that did it and what I do in those
situations I never talk to those people
again I just got up off the train got in
the next car and the dude I was with
said what are you gonna do about you
know
dude who took yourself and I'm like
it was hard for me to tell him like
probably not gonna do anything I'm just
not gonna ever talk to him again I
wouldn't even piss on him if he was on
fire
and that's all that I can do and also I
know that this person has a gun
you know so I'm not I'm not gonna risk
my life because I want to be a father
someday dude you know and you said
family on the wall dude that's one of
the first things I walked in the door
and realized
sorry
you might be one of the best
opportunities to given a glimpse into
homelessness and mental illness and drug
addiction let me ask you a question and
see
what your answer is
um what stops you at 26 years old you're
healthy
from just getting a job and getting your
life together
what stops me
drug addiction
well it's not the drugs that stopped me
you know there's not a bad Crystal of
math at the doors and stop you know
it's my desire to do them
um that becomes
like sometimes it's it subsides and
sometimes it's not even there
but then like
the more I let life build up
in my head like all these like
the more I don't handle the things that
I need to handle
the stronger that urge becomes and like
I'm talking like things that I didn't
need to handle like where I put off like
going to get my ID or the more I put off
like
um not getting a phone the more I put
off not going to therapy for my mental
health
the bigger these problems get and then
the more I just want to like not deal
with them because like
if I have a problem today
and then tomorrow it gets bigger I'm
going to want to deal with it less
because it's a bigger problem you know
what I mean my appetite is only so big
you know and then if it's bigger than it
was yesterday
you know I it doesn't make sense
um
but right now I'm really getting to a
point where like
like I want to go to detox and I want to
go to rehab dude I want
like I it's what I used to want to want
to get sober no I just want to get sober
dude like I'm at that point you know if
that makes sense because they say you
have to WAND it and it's like I didn't
get that before
but now it's like dude I would give
anything to like
to wake up to that boring life every day
that I just think was so boring you know
instead of this stuff you know it was
like
I want to get back with my sister I have
one person I really only call family now
because like My adoptive family
technically legally is not my family
anymore
because they I was put back his award
um
and then I have my brother who is too
much like my father I don't want
anything to do with him and then I have
my sister who is a um
she is a
advocate for at-risk youth
is really cool
and she lives in Australia she did this
all on her own
in
she went through the same things that I
went through
but
I don't want to say to the extent that I
did though because once you got into
foster care like she got placed with
kind of like the white picket fence you
know
um
stream American Home the American family
and she like she heard about some of the
[ __ ] that I was going through and it's
just like
you know and she was afraid
that if she reported it then it would
get back around to my mom and then I
would get reprimanded even more you know
but um I'm really like I love my sister
dude
we're a lot of like
like my good qualities she has we share
a lot
you speak to her so yeah every now and
then but it's hard for me to talk to her
because
like I start crying
um
because I miss her so much
foreign
like every time I talk to her to be like
sad you know
so until I have my life together
I try to just
stay out of hers
because it's stressful knowing that
there's
so when you live out there in the world
who doesn't care about them it's almost
as though it seems
and that there's really nothing you
could do
I have nothing this is going to be this
emotional
ah
but eventually like
I would like to go to Australia and live
in Australia with her and have our
family just be one big family
you know she just had a kid
I'm like
I don't know what you but I mean she
gets a baby still but I don't know what
she's gonna tell him about if she's even
gonna tell him even if I do meet the kid
like because I her and I both know like
the um consequences of like people
coming in and out of your life
throughout your childhood it's not good
it's not healthy
creates a lot of Discord in your
emotions
which creates a lot of unstability
this is not good for a child
so I wouldn't blame her if she like
wanted to see me doing well for years
before she introduced me to a child
but that hurts dude
so much
and this is why I want to get sober dude
because I'm feeling the pain
it's pain that I created
because like
it was my decision to pick up drugs
and it was my decision to not deal with
my problems
nobody else's
nobody like
shove the pipe down my throat
nobody did any of that
I don't know
do we still talk yeah you're in there
but like I only really call her when
there are changes in my life
you know
because it's pointless
otherwise
what emotions do you go through mostly
Aaron
not these ones
um
usually I'm pretty even keel
politely I've been like ever since
before we started I told you about what
happened to my friend the other day
that really screwed me up no that was
like a week and a half ago and lately
I've been like
really irritable really like and I know
why because I'm not happy with my life
right now like I used to be comfortable
you know just getting on and doing what
I do and you know being a hippie or
whatever
that used to be my comfort zone because
and now I know that is because I stayed
in it for so long
but now that like my eyes are opening
and I'm like
no pun in time but the haze is glaring
you know
I'm seeing like
I'm not comfortable here anymore
I'm not
I don't want to say here but I'm not
comfortable with me anymore you know
um
I forgot the question oh the emotions so
yeah lately I've been really irritable
um snapping at people
um
and I told you I don't really fight I
don't know
I feel like I'm about to like
fight somebody a lot of the times
but that's one of my things that I like
I hold a lot of value in
because like violence just gets no one
anywhere
if you want to fight somebody put some
gloves on and go into a ring
you know but if not like
be a man and talk it out you know that's
what will solve your issues
communication you know
so I like kind of pride myself on the
fact that like I've never
and when I say I don't fight I don't
like my white little girl I use my words
you know
and then like I kind of like
when somebody like wants to like uh try
to bully me into fighting I still use my
words and like I call them out on their
crap
and
like they feel really small you know and
in a [ __ ] way you know
but I try not to spend a lot of time
down here because a lot of times down
here people
are not uh not like they will just pop
off on you
sometimes for no reason
you know
but uh before the stuff that my friend
happened um I was pretty even Keel like
I said I was comfortable you know
um I was comfortable with my life
you know
um I was trying to think of a motion a
word emotions um
I can't say happy I was not happy
but I was content
um
a little sad because I I deal with
depression
[Music]
um
but yeah content
that's an emotion right
rejected being five years
pardon would you like to be in five
years
I want to be in school noon I want to be
a doctor I mean
that's something that's all I've always
wanted to be
I didn't realize when I was a kid that I
wanted to be a doctor I just knew that I
wanted
to be something that
I wanted to work in a profession that
encompassed a large field if that makes
sense and your PhD does you know like a
doctor of
like probably psychology
you know I would be like all knowing of
the brain you know or whatever you know
and like
even
today like people come talk to me
here and there about something they're
going through and I'm pretty good at
like picking it apart and like with the
components and like you know maybe like
giving them insights to why you know
what they might be doing whether they're
doing or the insight as to why somebody
else might be doing what they're doing
to them you know so I feel like I've
kind of got a good uh head on my
shoulders to be a doctor if I can get my
life together and keep it together
but uh yeah I want to be in school I
want to be working on my PhD
Aaron what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um
that uh
I don't know if this is a lesson or a
fact or whatever
but
they say this is a quote from a book it
says we trudge the row of happy destiny
more will be revealed to us and to
others
there's always something more to come
you know
there's always
there's always a bigger picture
always
and if you think that's wrong you need
to look at the Wikipedia you know
um
yeah and why why is that so important to
me
because for so long like when I was a
kid my life was so small you know I
guess I kind of that's where I got
screwed up is thinking that life was
that small
and just automatically like
like just like
feeling sorrow because I'm like oh my
God life is so small you know and just
thinking that that was it and I realized
that life could be bigger and would be
bigger for me maybe I wouldn't because I
turned to drugs when I was like like an
adolescent not even a teenager like I
was I started smoking
cigarettes when I was nine
I started smoking weed when I was 11.
took my first drink when I was 12. I
started doing opiates when I was 13.
like I started taking like prescription
opiates when I was 13. you know
and then
went from prescription opiates to
[ __ ] to uppers you know when I was
18.
you know
just bigger picture you know it's more
in life
and then what we see
all right Aaron thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you thank you
for having me I wish you the best of
luck with your
with your Pursuits and homelessness and
all that and I hope you help you become
a doctor one day that'd be right thank
you that'd be awesome to see thank you
thank you man we appreciate it